somewhere I read that when you were
doing your contract for data for the
movies that you put in the contract that
I'll do this but you have to put me in
another movie ever each time is that
true well the first movie I felt I had
some leverage because which actors
rarely has yeah so when you have to be
particularly basically I said look I'm
not doing it unless you know I make x
amount of money and more importantly I
get another role only did that once that
there has to be something that's not
Star Trek that Paramount Pictures is
doing right now but there was a clause
in it that if they didn't find another
movie for me to do uh they had to pay me
off see I thought the movie was maybe
Independence Day no but in fact before
that all came to a finish I had already
gotten Independence Day so I didn't
really care whether they found me
another movie I